I am NOT I think I think Trump last act
I don't like his behavior he mocked a
reporter getting body-slammed
I'm not a fan of these these these these
journalists and everything like but
right there's a certain demeanor that I
expect to the Office of the President
and that's why I've never been a big fan
of Trump
yeah his tact is is not the best I don't
care I'll be the first to admit that you
know sure and it totally played into the
story you know that the whole narrative
that orange man bad you know because
he's he is not a politician he is a
showboater and it loves attention
mm-hmm that's obvious and I look I I
have more disdain for the media than him
yeah and they lie about him all the time
so does that most of the general public
doesn't it but that Trump said something
I I could I want to make sure I'm
getting this right but I really remember
him saying something like I'm a mean guy
but I work for you
and so that I found funny I also really
loved when he was like I ran for office
one time he became president he's a
funny guy
he's funny too yeah yeah but my things
like or he toyed with the idea for a
long time though
I think he knows I think he knows what
he's doing yeah I gotta be completely
honest I don't like him he's funny
okay ah there's some things that it like
he's doing I'm willing to vote for him
mostly because of the war stuff and I'm
also because this this guy this guy
here's nuts he's Joe Biden is just
ridiculous i but what scares me more
about this this guy is who's behind this
guy because administration the
establishment exactly that's right so
I'm and I'm in this position where
there's like there's a lot of you know
moderate individuals intellectual dark
web types or whatever they call them
where it's like there's there's a lot of
reasons to be upset about this cycle and
for me for the longest time I've been
like I mean last year I was like I'm
never voting for Trump it's like look I
get it I get the culture where all the
stuff but listen there there really is
the character issues and integrity
issues tact issues arrogance ego you
know but you know what I don't care
about any of that if it comes down to
him signing that order to bring our
troops back and he's been trying to and
they're blocking him and they're
smearing him yeah and so I'm sitting
here saying you know what we got about
we have less than four months
I want to if he actually takes some very
substantive action I will I will gladly
walk in there be like yep stamp right
write it right on that running that line
because the way I see it is what is Joe
Biden gonna get us under Obama the the
racial tensions were escalating the
while in Chinese rule I mean that's
that's it protect potentially you know
it's just I'm talking about all the
problems we face today could Joe Biden
snap his fingers and make Cove and go
away of course not
but it'll happen Andrew and well we joke
about it but look Andrew Cuomo caused
all those problems including me and and
Murphy and and and and their problems in
Connecticut the tri-state was a disaster
yep so if Biden was president with that
change no of course not
with the rise have changed no what could
Joe Biden do to prevent the George Floyd
incident was he gonna magically like
parachute in as it was happening and say
hold I'm super Biden to stop this cuz
I'm psychic no it would have happened
and I'm totally not racist now it's
possible that the media wouldn't have
gone nuts with it and they'd simmer down
because the orange man bad narrative his
cash cash money for these businesses but
I think you you you bring in Biden and
you get more of Obama and a lot of
people are gonna laugh right now but we
liked Obama that's fine that's fine if
you if you like the wrapping of the
authorization for use of military force
the Middle East that's fine if you like
the indefinite detention provisions
under the NDAA the extrajudicial
assassinations of American citizens the
killing of women and children the use of
the Espionage Act I can make that can go
on for a fairly long time no you can't I
don't want this guy to come back and
bring back his stupid nonsense yeah and
so I look at Trump and I'm kind of like
yeah yeah yeah the economy was good I
get it but then the Afghanistan thing
happens there they're now trying to
accuse you know Russia was putting a
bounty on soldiers and I'm like that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard okay
it's art it's been disputed but you mean
to tell me that the Taliban that already
wants to kill American soldiers needed
help needed incentives to do it shut up
yeah someone was giving me a hard time
about that like trying to convince me
that that was the case and I just kept
asking for sources no no you just say
wow really oh man we should definitely
bring him back to bring him home yeah I
better bring them back before they get
hurt because because you agree right
Trump's not gonna help them right yeah
we better bring them all home imagine
what we can do if all that energy we put
over there oh and
and truth be told we have reduced our
forces over there substantially
especially yeah under Trump I think
there's like eight thousand six hundred
or so remaining I'm not entirely sure
but imagine if we took all of those
people and said here's Flint we need to
we need to refit all these pipes and get
that light out there clean that water
yeah about that how about that guys that
sound like great oh we're talking about
this this just came up the Pentagon says
the US has withdrawn from five bases in
Afghanistan after the Taliban agreement
I didn't I didn't ask today I'd make him
moves I didn't ask to do anything for
for what I think needs to happen but you
know what happened though right he just
did it no he is straight up what time is
it 8:30 he's watching the show right now
executive order we're gonna we're gonna
name this one you get the pool the pool
move no I don't know he's watching the
show on his phone and he's like sitting
in the Oval Office he's like so these
these city liberal guys that Ed wanna
stand out guy he's a he's all right yeah
he's gonna do like a rally Jenny black
Adam Craig ler I was watching the show
it's a good best podcast Tim cast IRL
this guy he says I'm gonna vote for
Trump good man
I mean to be honest crazy things have
happened to me like this I'm not joking
people watching the show whatever just
my life has been one amazing thing after
another so you know I'm lucky I'm a
lucky person well maybe we're in a
simulation and you're the the main
character so when the civil war breaks
out whoever's actually running the game
is gonna be playing you and you're gonna
be running into a wall like jumping for
no reason yeah but I I think I've beaten
the point to death but it's like it's
it's it's a weird feeling
living through Obama where he made a
promise and then broke that promise as a
serious promise mm-hmm
and it was hoping change and then too
for me to be like I'm not voting for
that guy I'm not gonna vote for him or
her and now Trump's like I'm withdrawing
troops in these bases and I'm kind of
like I didn't even ask him to do it
right you know and so you literally just
said it though like 10 minutes ago
that's why I'm like I'm suspect thanks
for watching the show
what's up president he makes a phone
call mr. president get out you sir I
don't have gana Stan so that the the
the Liberals are happy it's the weirdest
thing to me operation the pools closed
that's that's that though I'm watching
you chat you guys are great they say
things like they say things like there's
security reasons we don't know that's
why we're over there
and if we leave as a power vacuum and
all that stuff right and I just I'm
sorry man you know if you're concerned
about the expansion of these foreign
powers and a power vacuum in the power
vacuum in the Middle East
why aren't you concerned about the death
of the middle class they lost the
manufacturing base and all these other
things that Trump has addressed as well
yeah and that's why I'm kind of looking
at this like I'm not even my focus was
never even like are we gonna bring our
factories back it was never a part of my
you know my worldview yeah cuz I didn't
work I worked in media and journalism
but covering a lot of these things I was
like this the Middle East was the
biggest blunder and I blame Bush it was
a it was a it was reactive it was stupid
I think they use 9/11 as an excuse and
now Trump's doing something I can't I
can't make the president do anything I
can't make Biden do anything I can't
make Obama do anything all I know is
right now I have one vote and if Biden
gets in he'll do 50 billion things I
don't like if Trump gets in will do 50
billion things I don't like okay well at
least I'll get one thing that's
extremely important extremely important
it's almost like that one move of
bringing the troops back and ending this
ridiculous BS occupational war whatever
want to call it is worth a hundred votes
a thousand votes
you know Trump can go in there and say
he's gonna end canceled culture with you
know strongest I could have order
section 230 or form and I'm like yeah
yeah yeah yeah those are things are
important to me but it's like for every
for every one key it wedge issue you
have ten thousand you know points
towards how bad the war is so mister
mister president oh yeah you're
listening Reform 230 yes huge yes it's a
it's really important for freedom the
freedom of speech for the future very
important and the war on drugs
definitely legalized at the federal
level remove marijuana from was it
schedule one yeah is a Schedule one
narcotic yeah that's
saying I agree schedule one is nuts I'll
tell you what do let's do let's let's
create a review board that goes through
every single nonviolent conviction and
then grants think pardon or commute
what's the difference well if you're
pardoned you're not a felon if you're
commuted you're you're free to go
but you're still a convict hmm I think
party then full pardon yeah because and
then you know liking it legal then then
it wasn't a crime the one of the
concerns is that people say that some
people may have pled pleaded down okay
so those are the cases that will be
Commun then maybe commute or commute if
somebody if somebody is a violent
murderer but they caught them on drug
charges and they know and they've good
suspicion okay my position was innocent
until proven guilty if the state did
make their case but it is still fair to
say the state may have walked away from
more serious violence charges if they
knew they would get harsher drug charges
I mean the whole the whole crime bill
thing that I was learning about it's
like that that prevents felons or anyone
actually it specifically states if you
are incarcerated at all in the merit in
the American system anywhere you are not
allowed to further yourself you can't
get a degree and I think that is
ridiculous that needs to be repealed
immediately I'll tell you what I'll do
and that's part well that's part of what
we're talking about though right now
it's like for those people if they are
in there it should be about becoming a
better person and and and getting a
degree and they stopped that back in
1994 and that was Biden by the way if
who did that before Election Day Donald
Trump withdraws our troops in the middle
from Afghanistan mm-hmm I don't I don't
think we've that many left in Iraq
anyway I think it's only a few hundred
so ideally both and he pardons
nonviolent marijuana related offenses
I'll put him a get do oh you're wearing
Marga Hammond if he does that now that's
that's a bold that's that's because like
you can't deny it at that point you
can't I know all of those people who are
locked up for something as dumb as pot
all of the all of the people we have in
the Middle East who should not be there
our soldiers should be brought back home
so those are two groundbreaking historic
moves that could be made I would
absolutely just be a lie absolutely
Trump absolutely you do those things
that's just me though and so you know I
always want to make it clear like I
don't know what other people want I
don't know that other people need for
their lives I know a lot of people out
there just want freedom yeah they want
to live their lives and I I'm pretty
sure that's most of the country I wonder
if if I don't know if Trump has the
ability to remove marijuana from us from
the scheduling system no no no mm I have
to be Congress I'm not sure but I know
he can probably issue an executive order
instructing no more enforcement of you
know federal marijuana laws you know it
would go down to the states but even if
he did that and then all of these
nonviolent violent offenders on
marijuana charges
yeah we're pardoned and that was a lot
of people it's a lot yeah I'd throw a
party I put up a banner yeah and and
troops in the Middle East yeah I'd
probably man I don't even how to
describe it I'd probably go fly I put up
a flag or something you know though but
but you know I got I got imagine that's
like I'm talking about winning a lottery
I don't think that'll ever happen I
don't think Trump would do that I don't
know he's doing a lot for the minority
communities people keep trying to like
claim that he's a racist and I'm just
like you you you until you know how much
he is done for the minority communities
in this country you're not allowed to
say that to me anymore
because all I hear is that you are
ignorant of what he's actually done
because I know what he's done I've
looked at his policies of people on I
have a thread on my page right now I'm
like what what have I what do I not know
what what has he done that you know that
you like and there is hundreds of
comments and it is countless stuff you
know it's just incredible that he's done
for our country
and I haven't just like read the thread
and been like oh that sounds great I've
took each individual thing cross-checked
it read the actual bills that he put out
and they are impressive so if you think
he's racist go look at what he's done
for the minority communities and then
talk to me the media's go-to for
Republican presidents is racism and it's
partly because right that's the that's
the that's the issue they use to make
sure they like they want to convince
minority voters not to like you know to
be it was in the documentary they talked
about it they tell you this you know
they told Kanye that if he didn't
support them he would lose his career
and things like that
and that's when he blew up and had
mental issues and it's like I listen I
listen to his speech or the it was like
they call it I'm calling it a speech but
it was his rant before the show and it
was just him telling people to wake up
and do their own research that they're
being lied to and it's like mmm sounds
like he was just trying to drop throat
you know make it rain red pills because
he was like standing up on a platform -
so no wonder they tried to shut him down
Trump has a one of one way they get him
is that he just blurts things out all
the time that's true and sometimes
you're like what did he just say like I
can't what it's confusing and it's
almost like you know the intercept it's
really funny the intercept is very
progressive and they rag on Trump all
the time but they called him the most
honest president in history of the
United States yeah because he's got no
filter it's true
but he does lie about like they point
out that he's dishonest about things
that are kind of weird about like
personal issues and ego issues so if he
feels slighted he'll be like I have the
biggest numbers nobody has bigger
numbers than me and they're like why why
why you know it's like you know well I
mean I I know a lot about him and I'm
gonna save it I'm actually gonna do a
deep dive on him this Saturday within on
my show Adam Cass Tyrell so if you would
like to come check that out I'm gonna
I'm gonna dive deep into who Donald
Trump is what he's done I'm gonna we're
gonna go nuts so this Saturday 8:00 p.m.
you could check it out Adam Cass Tyrell
if it feels like the the very famous
moment I'd bring up all the time because
the intercept intercept reference this
was young he's doing being asked by a
journalist and he goes we're gonna do a
great weapons deal with Saudi Arabia
they're gonna buy tons of our weapons
it's great for the economy and all the
progressive anti-war people just like
just said it you're not supposed to say
that you didn't care but then it's like
when it comes to ratings and stuff right
he'll be like I'm the biggest and the
best and people like point out like
that's not sure why is he lying about
that like his ego stuff is weird but
then he'll just be open and honest but
these other weird things you know like
that's not supposed to I don't know man
look you know I think the important
thing to bring up - a lot of people who
are big fans of Trump yeah is that when
you're having a discussion with somebody
on the left you really need to
understand they have a deep visceral
rear
action of disgust when they when they
when they see him when they hear his
name yeah and you're not arguing against
facts you're basically telling someone
to imagine a giant ball of mucus blood
and pus pulsating that disgusts that
they feel that's an it's a raw emotion
that's very hard to overcome because
their view has been shaped by it's not
just the media line Trump has tacked any
problems you know she does he just
blurts things out and it makes it really
even and from and ego problems which you
know it's like puts his name and big
gold letters on top of buildings thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune into
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you